so something crazy happened last night
i finished jk news
i go home and by home i mean jill's
mom's house
i eat i take a shower i'm laying in bed
trying to wind down about to get ready
to go to sleep i got another day of jk
news today
and on the explore page of my instagram
this audition not just audition open
audition pops up
look at that
which never happens
and it's for a taiwanese guy
for a
all asian american show written by asian
americans
and i was like
is this a sign or something because
usually on my explore page it's like
military stuff trucks
dogs fitness
sports stuff occasional hot girls i
don't know how they get there but
there's hot girls in there sometimes
and i'm like
this might be a sign or something
so
i look at the instructions oh and the
reason why i say it's open audition and
why that's important because usually
like once you get to the bigger projects
the regular auditions you need like an
agent or a manager someone in the
industry to know how to plug you and
pitch you and all that
and um because the open auditions are
usually for the smaller projects like
student films and and stuff that are
going to go to like uh maybe like lower
level film festivals because the bigger
projects with money they want to make
sure you're seasoned you know so you got
to have representation and in order have
representation you must have done a
bunch of other projects so the open
audition part is key which is you could
just be anybody anyone but it's also
series regular which means it's not just
that one guy in that one episode they're
gonna come on a little bit and i was
like oh [ __ ] this is crazy
so i end up studying
for it i'm just practicing practice
practice i study from like 9 p.m to 11
just to make sure i can get it cause i'm
really rusty when it comes to acting and
even memorizing lines and i was like yo
i got a couple friends
uh that are actors i'll hit them up for
help because now the audition process is
different back in the day you would go
into the studio and then you would
audition in front of them and they tape
you now it's a lot of self tape
and i hit up tesh and i was like wait a
second tesh is coming today
and he's like yo print out the sides and
i'll help you out
so it just feels crazy because things
that never happened before are happening
and then things are lining up you know
like i never get auditions on my
explorer page just pops up i need help
and one of my buddies was an actor who
gets all kinds of projects it's also
coming the next day when i'm only in la
every two weeks anyways and it's a open
audition for a big project
so i'm like whoa i think i have to do it
this is freaking
crazy and the thing is
most auditions you don't get like if you
ask any working actor they'll tell you
most auditions you're not going to get
you're just going out there practicing
practicing practicing because sometimes
they don't even know what they want they
just want to see people read on screen
and see if that's the character that
they design
so who knows
but i have a good feeling about this
so
i'm gonna just be like [ __ ] it let's try
it you know and i'm gonna print out the
sides and when he comes in later he's
gonna help me and then you guys get to
see
how a real actor
does some [ __ ]
ah
oh man it's blown
yes
this is my jk
tradition
i always get
steak and eggs
and the reason why i get steak and eggs
is when i just eat like a small little
breakfast
when we're
filming
you use our brains so much that i get
hungry in like an hour and then i have
all these delicious snacks
boba milk tea mochi
all these
chips
that's not too bad but we have all these
freaking snacks and i'm not on a strict
diet right now but i still try to eat
nutrient dense things so for example
like when i'm on a diet i'll eat like a
sirloin steak right which is leaner and
i'll have veggies
when i'm not on the diet i still want to
hit my protein requirements i'm still
trying to build muscle so i'll get like
a rib eye with mashed potatoes and
cheese and bacon and all that good stuff
on it you know
so i still want to get like nutrient
dense foods
and so if i just eat stuff that usually
comes on a shelf
none of that has anything to really help
me build muscle so
my my favorite things to get is steak
and eggs and i've been getting it from
cairo's
and they don't make it anymore and
that's fine because i get my food from
this place called the pantry now and
we've done vlogs at the pantry it's like
a downtown l.a breakfast staple and i
got breakf uh steak and eggs
look at their potatoes dude it's crunchy
see that oh
got my little steak wish the steak was
bigger but
can't complain and they literally have
the best french toast in the world like
that's what they're known for they have
endless french toast if you ever go to
downtown l.a and eat at the pantry
just don't worry about the bread they'll
keep bringing it and the french toast
oh it's literally the best you could
just keep eating it more and more and
more and more
just getting my uh
get my little ketchup ready
to eat because
i've been working about like two hours
now and people are gonna start showing
up
so i want to be able to eat get ready
and get ready to film
all right so we got a professional actor
tesh here and he's going to give me some
pointers the brother son you sure you
want to put this online is this for you
these are secrets for you i'm trying to
get you the role oh really i mean it's
up to you yeah just give me some
pointers okay so pointer number one
pointer number one yeah don't [ __ ]
suck okay how do i do that that's the
hard part i did dude okay so i just
interpreted it
let me ask you something have you read
the script yes you have yeah
this i believe this is a script from
another episode or another show though
because uh the guy's name is bruce the
person i'm auditioning for his name is
mike
they could there's no bruce character in
the script
well it says bruce on the script
but on the side but on the sides but the
person i'm auditioning for his name is
mike
okay
so they want is everyone auditioning for
bruce do you know
like are all the males who are dashing
and good looking auditioning for bruce i
don't know [ __ ] about this project i'll
tell you how this came to be this is a
good start i was i was i was i was
laying in bed
last night after jk news relaxing
and on my explore page uh it pops up i
saw i saw this yeah yeah and then i was
like is this a sign
so i have the object it was targeted i
have marketing no i haven't auditioned
for anything in probably over eight
years eight years and then one last
thing do you remember the last thing
no no no no no no no it was so it was a
show it was a hbo show and i don't even
remember the name of the show anymore oh
but lawrence helped me prepare for that
one
but obviously i didn't get it
okay or else i wouldn't be here but
anyways
all right so um
you want to read it with me sure i don't
know if you could put this online though
all right if you read it with me we
can't put it on okay fine but what are
some pointers for anyone that's looking
to audition for anything is there
i would say if you have the script read
the script uh a lot of times
yeah
knowing what other characters say about
your character is a great way to gather
information for script analysis yeah you
know the same way if i like their
perspective that yeah because that tells
you a lot about who you're playing okay
um along with what your character
obviously does
what's up dude where's the zyrtec at
dude i'm over here
oh dude that's what you were saying
about allergies
but i woke up sneezing like a [ __ ]
[ __ ] how many do i take they are
ruining my acting class yeah i was
getting are you guys oh you guys we're
doing it we're doing it bro this is
called a table read i see this in the
movie oh [ __ ] look at all these
technical terms yeah it's almost like
you guys want to act in school with yeah
they've wasted all that money that's
actually [ __ ] production that's
pre-pro that's what i call it
so what are some tips okay gotta know
what the other characters yeah about my
character yeah uh i always recommend
memorizing your lines okay some people
don't they call that off book yeah
off book you know
dude i'm like oh dude i'm like nick
doing everything
um what else what other stuff can i tell
you
that this is giving away i was going to
leave
his acting secrets
uh that i could tell you for free yeah
because i know how this business works
yeah you have to pay me that's true
how does that work do i have to start a
patreon yeah
all right he's going to coach brian i'll
talk to you guys later i forgot i was
holding on to it oh wait you have a
grill oh [ __ ]
that's a little john right there oh [ __ ]
hey that's a little jar right there
you're icy bro oh was that jade
do you have to get them custom fit to
your teeth or is it like a generic size
no you have to go get a mold
holy [ __ ] that's crazy you know what's
like happening let me get closer let me
see one like clip but it's like in
sections how come you got so many pieces
because she's boxing is that my support
yeah
so that's what i mean custom the design
is custom like the the artwork mm-hmm
everything's best yeah so i've always
wanted jade i love jade so that's why i
wanted this one
oh [ __ ] where's that one
when do you take it out and when do you
put it in you take it out when you eat
when you want to flex bro come on man
see i don't know these cool guy things
that's pretty tight dude cool guys these
are cool guy things dude
that is cool people share cool culture
girls are cool culture i'm not the only
part of that complex con crowd
i'm kind of lame dude
i know
because he's going to pick up his
footage so i'll just interrupt in
between your guys's tastes thank you
wow this is how all his magic goes down
that's coordination
wow sneak peek dude
wow this is hot
look who decided to show up oh sure no
i'm just kidding
yeah today's not even yesterday
yesterday we shot jk news
there yeah cause uh i showed them that
we were uh hanging out jk we had teshon
twyon and after we're done i was tired i
went home and then my brother gave me a
really cuny surprise she goes i'm coming
tonight i'm like woo-hoo
you didn't do that you like i was like
hey i'm coming tonight and then it was
like four hours of silence and i was
like
huh
and then i started talking to my mom and
my brother and stuff and they're like i
think he's sleeping and i'm like four
hours of silence no when you see her
coming tonight wasn't i still here
i don't know yeah yeah so i was probably
filming and then i came home and then i
was like okay come away from mama and i
fell asleep and i'm so tired so she came
yes when you came i wasn't able to
vlog or nothing but today this morning
we trained and now we're back here on a
day that we're not shooting jk so it's
cuny that we get to work together and
mama made her famous
chicken
couscous yeah it was um it was tough
since i drive a tesla
um it took so i didn't like
for those of you that may not have a
tesla you can um you can charge the
battery the whole way but they don't
recommend it because then it like eats
up your battery life so they go oh just
there's like a driving range that they
tell you to stick to and then the car
i'll tell you too so i had it at that i
didn't think i was going to leave that
like yesterday
um so then i had to make so many stops
that it like our four hour
road trip
when you have just a regular gas car it
took me what was it
oh my god six hours yeah you got there
like 12 30 or so yes so i left vegas at
six and i got to la 12 30. i made three
freaking charging stops that is
unheard of and two of those were like an
hour each but i'm so grateful that you
came because remember i was telling you
guys i need to do that audition so i
said mob since margaret was here she
helped me read the lines off camera for
that self tape so i was able to send
that in this morning so i'm super happy
hopefully either the casting director
likes my performance or likes gio's
voice off camera and gets me the role
they're like yeah who's that off-camera
i'm not good whoa can we get her in here
that voice actor or that voice we need
that voice and then i become like
[ __ ] famous
just finished working sure you did
hey cuny mama do you like working with
me no you bugged dude really judy
promise um
you don't like working with me in the
office you like you are separate no i
like it i like working with you like
ideally if we had uh home offices would
it be like two separate rooms absolutely
really yeah you don't like my presents
uh i love your presents but i also like
when i'm in work mode yeah because we
don't it's not like we're collaborating
in our work yeah right it's like it's
your time sometimes it collaboratively
it's rare but it's like your thought
right and then it's it then i'll like
then it comes on my desk and i do what i
got to do right yeah or it's my thought
and then it lands on your desk and you
have to do specifically what you got to
do yeah so it's never one of those it's
like here let's put it on our desk
together it's like rare
that happens like with the executive
planning then
that's that's like rare right like that
happens like at the end or the beginning
of the year yeah or if there's like
these one-off events that we really have
to plan for yeah
yeah but i do like my own space
i've noticed
why don't we um have our offices split
one in one room one in the other room
then
do we have that kind of room i mean we
do have one room that's for a guest that
we don't use that much
i think we've used it a few times
already when we have someone downstairs
and then someone upstairs
or what if we bought one of those
cubicle dividers and split it down the
middle
you know one of those furry cubicle
dividers but hurry yeah the ones that
like people hang their kids pictures on
it's like it's a carpet material you
know
you can put it down the middle
we can do that i mean it's not a big
deal it's not a big deal it's just i
think because you're asking yeah but
like the way we have it now is cool
i just zone in and lock myself into my
headphones and you do the same yeah the
only thing that sucks is when we do have
to meet like at the skype meeting or
something
then one of us has to leave the room if
the other one is meeting oh yeah cause
it's all loud yeah or we both can't meet
at the same time yeah we both can't be
on the phone at the same time that's so
true that's rare though i mean the fact
that i have an office though or like a
space that i that i can have a desk in
i'm just grateful for already so what we
have is cool but if i had
if we had like multiple rooms or we can
like run an office and we have like
office spaces yeah i would want my own
space
all right meanwhile when i was working
remember i dropped off my truck um a day
or two ago so make sure you watch that
vlog at the shop they sent me some
updates and i'm like
look at that
zam's walk okay you have to explain it
to them because you're showing it so
that one's fine but you were showing me
somewhere i'm like where on the truck is
this like what is it all right so if
you're not a car person like me yeah
don't and i'm like i and i know a little
bit more than like the average person
about do you some cars don't no don't i
when i said it was on the a pillar
you're like what's that
that's not that's already not average
really yes all right so average people
don't even know that they're short uh
long bed and short bed trucks that's
true
mommy yeah that's true come on now fine
so yeah this is my front bumper lights
and they got that orange masking tape
because they're cutting it i'm doing a
bumper chop and then i'm gonna put a
skid plate there
that's a close-up of it
pretty sick right
and then even the um what's the skid
plate dude so what the skid plate does
is it's a put at an angle so that if
you're ever to hit like a weird angle of
a hill going up or downhill um
what what to your face look at this huh
i know we're not we're not used to this
no more god damn oh [ __ ] that's a red
light my bad damn dawg i just didn't see
it because of this thing yeah even the
badass drive like [ __ ] no i drove like
[ __ ] now [ __ ] nevadan's yeah yeah the
skateboard it gives it the right angle
so that if you come in steep or if
you're like exiting steep um it helps
you not hit the bumper yeah that helps
you not hit the bumper and it just looks
clean but anyways um even with my lights
in the front like these this one's a
beam light these ones are floods meaning
this shoots further and the other ones
just kind of like are wider
that's a close-up of that
flood is shoot further beam is wider no
beam is further the beam beams and the
flood floods
okay all right i thought the flood was
going to flood you with [ __ ] light
and no blood so the floods go sideways
in this way
let's go sideways and beams
can you like beam something further away
i don't know [ __ ] no i don't [ __ ] about
that's what i've been trying to tell you
and then i got some rear bumper area
lights
and then
uh see that's the bumper chop see how
they chopped it looks dope it's all
tucked in like that you tell them about
your the the the new design that you got
on the side of your door
yeah they saw
joe crashed into my car anyways um
here's the a-pillar light so that's my
little fog light that i put on the
a-pillar and that's it
can't wait to get reunited with my truck
well the thing about the the bar i mean
joe hitting your car is not a big deal
ever um because material things you can
replace it right but i think the ironic
funny thing to me at least and it might
not be funny to you is that you had
literally just got your car back because
you just fixed it yeah i told them that
okay yeah sorry
no worries i don't know [ __ ] about [ __ ]
that's why don't open your mouth until i
ask you a question you understand that
shut the [ __ ]
so when in la i have to get
some tacos
i have yet to find a place in nevada
that has tacos
even close to comparable to the ones in
la um i could be wrong
and i can't wait for you guys to prove
me wrong but like
this right here is the spot or one of
the spots there's so many good spots out
here right now it is um
it is rush hour so like i have to park
in like this like business here i asked
them it was cool if i could stay here
they were like yeah totally cool
um but look at this it's like
this is just a residential street
a bumper to bumper dude
but you know i gotta get my
tacos look at this happy guy
i know dude so he's already been here
for two days and he said he had tacos
two days in a row today's gonna be day
three
talking some smack no what did you order
i got you uh
four assata tacos you're talking about i
got your bro hand suicidal tacos and i
got myself
damn am i
i hope that's enough food for me i think
i'm eating with my eyes you always do
but we also got salad at your brother's
house
do you know what a molita is
are you for real how come you never
order it's so delicious
i don't know i i fell in love with it
because i found out they're pretty much
a small quesadilla
oh
you say
yeah exactly how come you don't get how
come you never order molitas if you're
not good quesadillas are they might as
well get because i really want the tacos
but now go give me molita
um yeah when you said salad like
you're gonna get classified again like
you always do
you know what on that note i'm gonna
beat this fool's ass and i'll see you
tomorrow i see
see you later essay bye